we'll go ahead and get started I'm Bob
San Heinrich this is bernard SP you lie
so we're going to be doing a workshop
demonstration of data drop and
specifically burnouts gonna be showing
how we can use it with if this than that
so data drop is Wolfram's cloud-based
data aggregator service it's been we've
been out for almost a year now with it
live and and you know there's been a lot
of people using it if you saw Evan over
there give a give a nice talk yesterday
for a nice application of data drop with
political data and social media that was
it was pretty interesting there a couple
other people i think that are using data
drop as small parts of their talks so so
it's starting to work its way into into
this community and sort of the wolfram
world so for those of you who might not
be so familiar i'm going to do a quick
overview of what data drop is then i'm
going to show you how you can get
started using data drop show you the web
interface the so we have a day to drop
website and then show you how you can
use data drop from within the Wolfram
language whether that's Mathematica or
the cloud or wool from desktop and then
I'm going to do a couple of quick
examples before I hand off tip or not so
for the first for the first few minutes
there's not going to be a couple you
know I'm just going to be talking but
then you can feel free to try to follow
along when i'm on the website when i get
into the language i start have some the
input cells already written out so i
wouldn't try necessarily try to follow
along just sort of watch and then burn
ants examples might be easier if you
want to try to do things along with us
so like I said the data drop is a
service for for aggregating data but
doesn't just aggregate data it also
standardizes it and gets it into wdf so
so you know you can get all of your
entities as entities you can get dates
as dates you can get geo locations as
Wolfram geo locations you can get
quantities its physical quantity objects
you know it standardizes it into the
format that allows you to do all of our
great analysis with it and we've tried
to set of data job so that anything can
send us data so you can have anything
with an HTTP connection can make a
request to our API and add data to data
bin you can do it from a web form which
we make it super easy to deploy a web
form which you can use directly or you
can embed in your site you can do it
from the language lots of ways you can
tweet us data you can send us data and
email you can use if which pronounce can
show which is a super cool way to you
know add by a factor of 10 the number of
things that can add data today to drop a
couple things to make note of this is it
this is a service that lives in the
Wolfram cloud essentially anybody was a
cloud account could make their own data
drop this is this is not something that
we have special abilities to do this is
a service written mostly in the Wolfram
language living in our cloud that we
thought would be a great service so we
made it and it's also integrated fully
into the language so we'll see that in a
minute so that the the fundamental unit
of data drop is the data bin this is any
person can have multiple data bins and a
data bin can have multiple users they're
defined by unique IDs they have both a
long uuid and a short ID you can set
permissions on your data bins and you
can define semantics for interpretation
which I definitely encourage people to
do it was it's what makes us special I
think as far as places to send data so
as I said you can add data from lots of
different sources
forums Twitter web forms i guess i've
already gone over this so just a quick
example here's a data bin i have and
i'll show you in a minute exactly what
this ugly stupid data is and how it was
made so once you have a data bin you can
use that data bin in the language just
as as a normal object so dateless plot
which is a function probably most of you
are familiar with you know it can work
with lists but it can also work directly
on a data bin which is always time
series data so since its time series
data things that work with time series
objects generally work with data bins so
that means you can access it from all
these all of our our systems Mathematica
program cloud and we also have Wolfram
Alpha summaries which I will also show
in a minute so the first interface imma
show is the the data drop website so I
yeah you guys can see that pretty well
right um so so this is the home page it
has some some blurbs about what we can
do telling you how great data drop is
there's there's also this quick
reference which I incur if you're
interested in data drop I highly
encourage you to look at this I'm not
going to go through it we don't have
nearly enough time but this is sort of
the main documentation for using data
drop so you can see I'm logged in here
and I can create a database just by
pressing the create a new data bin
button and this will give me a new data
bin you can see I have this ID here
that's the short ID and up in the URL
you can see the full ID for the bin you
can do anything you want you can name it
you can set permissions on the data bin
I'm not going to mess with it right now
because if if somebody wants to
frantically copy this ID into their
session they can they can add feel free
to add data to the spin as we go along
you can add
add entries to the data bin so this is
using the standard Wolfram form function
is just embedding it in an iframe on
this website i can add an entry i can
add another entry if i want so now we
created a data bin and i'm going to take
this ID i'm just going to copy it so
let's see should we look this isn't
going to be a particularly interesting
data bin to look at Wolfram Alpha but
from there you can you can you can view
data in your database and wolfram alpha
and this was just a couple of text
entries which won't be very interesting
what happened here oh well some
something something failed there I'm
okay we'll have to fix that so so once
you have this this bin ID you can use
this data bin from anywhere oops that's
the wrong one what am i doing
so so I can take that bin ID and put it
right into the Wolfram language and
access that same data bin I can see see
the entries I've made I can add new
entries so so once once you have a data
been any any interface with the Wolfram
language can access it and use it for
multiple places so so I said that that
data been with the stupid data that I'd
earlier is I was going show you how I
made it so so basically i just created
this data bin as i was creating this
notebook i evaluated this the set
options cell which basically says
anytime I I hit a digit key on my
keyboard while I was making this
notebook it added that value to data bin
so so you know you can create data bins
for lots of little tracking things that
you want to do so the this is you know
something something simple that just
sort of happens as I as I go along and
we can we can look at sort of the
metadata of this data bin using options
yes so as long if I'm in this notebook
yes so you sending the options of
evaluation notebook so anything I do in
this notebook until I quit the kernel or
change that option it will be able to do
that so yeah so if I click into a
different note book or to a browser
something that won't work anymore so if
we look at the options the search shows
the metadata and i created this
interpreter which is that domain data
semantics that i've been looking that i
was mentioned earlier so this is
expecting integers but this
interpretation can be much more
interesting things which will show in a
second so now that I have the data from
that data been you know like i said
earlier all of the functions that work
on time series or work on list of data
will pretty much work directly on the
data bin itself so each time I do one of
these things it's going out and checking
if there's any been any new data added
to the data bit
on the cloud and if not in it since I'm
not adding new data it's it's sort of
showing the same thing I can also as I
mentioned earlier Oh am I not
authenticated so some things require so
this this data been I think I made a
private for adding data anybody can read
data from it but only I'm allowed to
write to it so since I wasn't
cloud-connected it wasn't going to let
me create a web form for adding data but
now that I'm authenticated I can create
a web form so this is this is a web form
intercloud I can use this right here I
could embed it and what in my own
website and and so now you could see we
should have a 32 on the end of this
thing there we go all right so that's
sort of to sort of a super basic
examples no we're going to show one with
a little bit more interesting
interpretation so I'm going to create a
database looking for four values and
you'll have to bear with me this is a
this i created this example for when i
was giving a similar presentation which
was online and I could send people a
link so either we can just use the data
from that one or if anybody wants to try
to copy the or the ID into their
notebook we can do that but if i define
these fields so i'm looking for a
quantity in years i'm looking for a
country i'm looking for an animal and
i'm looking for a number so i can create
a data bin that's looking for those
values and when i deploy the webform to
that update there we go
so so this is so this is our smart forms
so i can fill it out a favorite animal
let's say a lie in how about eight years
all right so so the idea here is i can
take this web form and let you all see
it lets well we can do URL shorten and
it might not be as crazy so if anybody
wants to tell me where they're from and
their favorite animal they can they can
use this this short URL and then they'll
be able to add data but in interest of
expediency and i don't think we'll get
more than a handful will use that we use
the the bin from a previous exam from
when i did this before let's see
where is that one will copy this bin
this one has 110 results in it so it'll
be more interesting so you can see when
I gave this online we had a we had more
diverse countries although I we're
pretty diverse here so maybe so so once
I have the data in my session in you
know once I've brought it in from the
data bin you know I have all the
wonderful tools in the language for
working with you know Gio locations and
doing all sorts of neat stuff so I can
find all the capitals I can plot paths
from 0 type of there I can plot the the
geo paths from where we are to wear all
these all of these capitals are for
everybody that attended the talked
previously will pretend like it's you
guys and so so when I looked at this
before I asked to revive the values of
the data been so that sort of swords
them all and each each field is sort of
sorted as a list I can also ask for the
entries and they'll be sort of like the
transpose of that where each it's a list
of each entry so when I look at it this
way it's easier to sort of draw
correlations between different fields so
if I just get one person from each
country I can do a neat little this this
one takes a minute or I can pull in a
favorite animal from each country and
plotted on the map which is sort of
trivial but I I don't know of any other
systems that can really do that so
quickly and easily see we're still
running
where we'll come back and a little more
interesting we can create a data set set
from the data bin and you know we've
probably seen a lot of data sets and
talks already this is a version 10 or
10.1 edition i think but it allows you
to others my Geographics let's make that
bigger it's more interesting all right
alright so some of the images get
distorted but there's the idea see so
more useful is creating a data set from
the data bin so when I create a data set
it gives we all the data along with the
timestamps in the data bin and you can
query query this data in the language I
can look up all the people who filled
out the form that are older than then
Wolfram research using this date
difference and select so this is
selecting as an operator which is
something that I think was new in 10.1
also and once i have that result i guess
this is flow to looking up our founding
date the rest of it should probably be
pretty fast well we'll go ahead and
evaluate those so once I've done that I
can I can you know get an image of the
favorite animal of each of the people
that's older than Wolfram research
because that's what everybody was
wondering wondering so so this is just
sort of a those are there's our people
older than hold from so yeah so that's a
basic demo of how to get started with
data drop how to create data bins how to
use a web interface how to take a day to
ben from the web interface bring it into
the language access in the language and
shows how you can seamlessly get the get
the data that you put in your data bin
and start doing analysis and computation
so I'm going to let bur not take over
here thank you about for these nice
introduction to the data drop so my name
is Bernard spla and today I'm gonna talk
about the these then that service it's
an external service that well from now
it provides a channel where you can
connect to the different channels that
are available to this platform but so
the I'm going to talk about the these of
this platform and these are particular
channel war from data drop
in the 80s and that and then I'm going
to go through the different types of
recipes that you can create these are do
recipes and if recipes and then I'm
going to show two examples that you can
use a data drop with other devices for
example Arduino under a sweetie pie and
then I'm going to just go through the
function semantics import and data bin
upload it's summer bunch and advanced it
functions that you can use to get your
local data from your desktop or whatever
you you have it and send it to the cloud
so from the drop let me watch these so
if this then that this is a is an
external platform I encourage you to
download these free apps that they have
these are the two button the two camera
and the do note and then you have also
the app but and I'm going to explain how
how to use that using the devil from
data drop channel there are like
hundreds of different channels in there
so I could just give you an overview oh
it's label so it really increases the
exponentially the different sources that
you can get for 42 drop and you can get
really creative about what what do you
want to connect with so that there is
like connected home different services
I'm going to go through this one later
as an example then it that mobile at the
station but you have a feed bit we
already we can see here some services
that we are already interested to the
water language but it's as you wanna see
it opens more possibilities to have the
Wolfram data drop channel in this in
this kind of galaxies of different apps
and services so i encourage you to
download the apps and logging it's a
sign up through the service
so you're going to be able to connect
your more friendly to drop account do it
is than that and create your own recipes
so the recipes are our single button so
that it's going to be available in your
in your a smartphone or mobile device so
it just one with one tab you are going
to send data to your data drop a
specific data mean that you have and
then you have the recipes that are
composed by a trigger and then there is
an action the action is going to be in
this case to save the data to put two
data bin let's look at the apps that the
for example at the do button up an
example that I have here is a piece of
all you you must create a data bin well
let me start with a 80s than that so I'm
just going to go to if these and that
the service what's not
so I go to my recipes
here in my recipes you have the recipes
and the dough recipes the recipes it's
better to create to create them when you
are in your mobile device so you open
the app and you can create your own
recipes but for the recipes it's better
I find more useful to open them and
create them through the the web platform
the offer so you select the trigger
channel this case i'm gonna select
instagram and then you have to specify
the type of the trigger that you want in
this case i'm going to choose this one
so whenever the photo is sent to instead
i mean its public i'm gonna select the
area in these cases where we are having
the other conference so I'm just gonna
capture all the Instagram photos send in
this area where the wolfram technology
conference is covering so it's like here
so i create the trigger and then i
specify that the action in this case is
the Wolfram data drop channel so it's
like to add an entry through the data
beam so here I have to deploy the ID ID
of the data bin for this case I'm gonna
go here and create a database so once I
have this new data beam I just have to
take the short ID copied and pasted it
in the Indies field then you have to add
the ingredients that the data that you
want what we specific data bin for
Instagram you have different types of
ingredients that you cannot and one of
those say is the caption for example so
I'm just going to the caption but I'm
going to specify that the key look at
the key is the name of the key is gonna
be caption
equals and then I can add other
ingredients just by adding on and so for
example you can add the URL so i say
your l is equal to the the source URL
that is going to be providing the image
that we kind of we're going to be able
to import to mathematical later so i
could be adding more ingredients in this
case I'm just going to have only the
caption on the URL of the image so i
ended up create action and then I can
check and select to receive
notifications of when these are these
recipes running then I'm gonna receive a
notification to my mobile device so now
I'm looking just for some volunteers
that I want to take a selfie and Senator
instead am NOT just just giving it so
okay this I just I just created a recipe
it's that simple so that the recipes are
even simpler also you just have to to
deploy also the ID of the data being
that you want to send the data and for
example this case i'm taking the
latitude and longitude of my mobile
device in this field so whenever I but
this kid i must say that i've been
created i created they've been using the
function built in so i have this
interpretation going on so the Jade Geo
is going to interpret as a location so
when I am sending the latitude and
longitude numbers they're going to be
interpreted as a geo position so can
show you an example that i'm just going
to tap the from this table this tablet
so i'm going to save it to the bin so
now i have the location of this room and
for example in this case i was taking
the last two values and i live in
barcelona so I just
had these two values when I was up to a
hill and this is the other one was at
home so I could like measure that the
distance or like measure the multitude
of these are he'll respect to my home
and there are other things but I'm going
to try to run it and see if i detecting
another location because i was logging
the location at my hotel and now we're
going to have the delegation of this
this room as well sure it's going to
work the the internet connection is its
faulty for me ok let's let us keep that
so can do the same thing for the the new
camera app could be saving the location
and the photo as well so for example
here a gesture i was taking some photos
using this up and then you can visualize
them in the inner map the same for do
note you can see if it whatever you want
as a you values just was a measuring the
the mood so you can find your own
applications of it it's open to you here
is another example i created a different
recipes that were taking the install and
channel 2 but the way they were taking
images from different locations
different zoos in the wall is one of the
largest ones so I set up this a
different recipes that were sending data
to the same data bin so I had this
particular these that the data when I
had all the information available in
there so here is a representation of the
50 images
and then I use the image identify to
like filter out only the images about
the animals in this case I was able to
find what kind of animals were
photographing by the visitor so it's
quite a procedure that did they work
quite well yeah
and this was only just one day but you
can analyze the whole later it has been
running for several days so
that's a real one with you and then I
can take for example also like captions
of these Instagram photos and I can tell
the language that was spoken by the
visitors they were sending these these
photos can also like create the hash tag
cloud the war cloud of the hashtags of
these images or analyze the sentiment of
this post most of them are positives
using the Facebook topic a built-in
analyzer you can see that most of this
activity most of these posters about the
pets and animals I'm family and friends
so let's need to see that these
locations in the hairs are representing
these kind of topics and you have the
tools that okay the kheer is another
example is a created this recipe to
collect the text from Pinterest so I use
these to collect Twitter programs that
we are creating in this pinterest page
so here you have all these two the
problems i can has been selected from
the ones that you are sending and I
users so when I just click that I like
one of those I'm going to save the text
to the dative in sorry I'm able to take
the day that the code that I want from
this collection and then analyze it
later here I'm just taking the last
value of this data bin and it's giving
me the expression on the code so i can
just explore it in a notebook so it's an
easy way to go through it and and have
these hobbies the Pinterest working for
you finally there is another example at
the clock beat from little bit i have
the sample here so i can just throw it
you can check it out is it's just a
little [ __ ] is a platform may aim for
for for kids to explore a computation
and
tronox so you have different models and
different sensors in this case I'm just
using a sound trigger so with this Mabel
to to send data to date a drop one knee
triggers using the the abuse or not so I
place it these this trigger next to the
home telephone that they have it at home
so whenever it's ringing it's gonna be
saving an entry tool to this data bin so
he just the data from a goes to throw
October you have many other like
channels that you can use about
allocation from Android and iOS it's
available there so you can set it up to
trigger different things when you exit
exit home for example or enter home can
use the Fitbit Twitter the UA uvl I
index also its variable their newspapers
that there are a few of them New York
Times The Times and here is what the
netted more weather station that I have
at home so I created a recipe to to look
at values when when the sound level
rises or drops below a certain threshold
this case it's 50 decibels some when
this happens then I'm sending the data
to data drop so you can notice here that
I'm creating the data been using this
interpretation that I want the noise to
interpret it as a decibels so all these
values then are going to be with a
correspondent units the physical means
you have another point about the data
drop is that it allows you to analyze
this data directly throw wolframalpha so
even if you don't know about analyzing
data in the warfarin language or the
mathematica platform then you can use a
war from alfred analyze it and have some
insights but what is going on
so this is the nicest date is on
Thursday now I'm going to show that you
can also this is was using the if this
and that but now I'm just going to go to
directly to the website of netatmo and
there you can download from the cloud
they're all cloud the data that you have
been collecting with your station
weather station here in just selecting
these all the values from some from
September so I just imported them as a
CSV file so i used semantic import to
import all the values of these this file
so it was using all these properties to
interpret correctly different physical
units and ended up with this dataset and
when once i had this data said i just
added different analysis for example
here it was analyzing the average day I
have this is the co2 emissions the
particles per million but a drink night
it's a dress up and then doing the day
it's quite low when I have the windows
open or whatever and the noise is
different here that noise is low when
when we are sleeping and then it dresses
up doing the day so I think that iphone
useful is to use the tab in upload in
this case you can see that i'm just
taking small chunks of the data and
saying that sending that to data drop
because there is a limit so you have to
be careful about the size of your data
set that you want to send to the beat
drop the only thing important is that if
you want the time stamps to be
interpreted correctly you have to say to
set them with the name timestamp
in the sense that the values that the
key name it must be time stamped with a
capital P oh yes or it's just a small
detail so now next is just an example or
not data with Arduino yoon-hee clear
build up his own whether the station so
you're going to find this post available
in community Wolfram or wolfram blog was
also featuring this nice example so when
when when you send a disco 22 to the
Arduino you can see here is just going
to be adding the temperature using the
dipi of the data drop you just have to
change it with a your own idea that your
data bean ID and then it's going to be
saving that the temperature that is
monitoring the deal we know you know I
see the data using different things so
that's an application using an Arduino
and then for the Raspberry Pi I had this
a small like infrared motion sensor so
you can plug it up to the GPO of the
Raspberry Pi I was collecting the the
buffer and so when whenever happens at
the the whole of my my home so I was
collecting all these movements in there
and DN I was able to analyze several
months of data and I found that it was
easy to use data drop to monetize
devastated for throw another location
whatever you want even even send images
using the the rizvi by camera model to
date the drops way you can be adding
these photos there and actually I show
it how to make like a time-lapse i was
using this nice flower to show that when
you
I wasn't like what they need doing like
several days and then it was like down
but then I just put some water and it
get life again it's so we just go
through the way the way hope to create
the data being and then I just run a
scheduled task that was adding the
images thought who is a veteran so at
the end I ended up with this animation
yeah but i might say that it was a it
was not harm like I it was yeah I mean I
was not poisoning it's just one thing
after the it's in the sense that it was
like that and then with the water get a
life again so that's the the example but
you can do much more with the data drop
under class v by so finally ended but
i'm going to give you these are all
these resources that are available so i
just so thank you very much for your
attention